you got to me right you've got a big
enough social following right you DM me
I'm taking random one some people have
$6 some people have $250,000 and here we
are we're talking and you can reach out
to other people you should reach out to
people that are making content that fits
the tone of your music hit them up and
see if they'll use your music in their
content some guy makes a video that gets
oh look it's Casey
nice fab makes a video and uses your
song in it that can break you out
so so yes the district distributions
changed Good Charlotte is famous because
of Madden football a video game that's
just true and right now and right now in
a year I'm going to put a song in one of
my videos and that artists will become
famous off the fact that I have a huge
base and it gets passed on and by the
way there's tens of thousands of people
that have bigger audiences than me and
different genres playing on Twitch
playing on YouTube playing on Instagram
that you need to get so make great
[ __ ] music make it [ __ ] often and
find a ton of people that have audiences
to distribute it the end and never stop
until it happens
[Music]